[Music]
zoe kravitz and channing tatum pack on
the pda in italy she's one of the more
intentional people i've ever met in my
life well we don't know if zoe intended
for these snapshots to go viral but from
what we can see this duo is making the
most out of their european getaway
dining at cafes and enjoying the
mediterranean nightlife i'm really
blessed man and thank you shannon for
blessing us with these rare moments with
zoe while these two have been dating for
a while they've kept the pda to a
minimum romantic right but when in rome
or ponza island to get specific let the
pda fly and the lovebirds even shared
this sweet cuddle moment it's happening
it's been nearly a year since these two
started seeing each other and we just
learned the romance started with less of
a meet cute and more of a well just a
meeting as zoe tells the wall street
journal she called shannon in to discuss
a role in her directorial debut a film
called [ __ ] island darling
yeah shannon booked the part and while
there's not many details about the
thriller joey teases he plays a quote
dark character zoe also tells the paper
she could tell shanning's a quote
feminist and that he wasn't afraid of
exploring that darkness that's why i was
drawn to him and i wanted to meet with
him and i was right i definitely don't
play any one that i've ever played
before in this in this movie yeah
shannon's told us to expect someone
quite different from magic mike and this
is just a completely categorically
different thing and it was one like
really awesome to like to be thought of
in that way that i could do that and
then also you know a very specific
point of hers was just like look i i
really know that she really made or saw
me i guess while zoe doesn't go into
their relationship offset in her new
interview she does offer up this quote i
guess what i'll say is that when you
make things with people it's a very
sacred space and when you're compatible
with somebody creatively it often opens
up other channels i'm really grateful
that this movie has brought him into my
life that way i can tell you it's it's
incredible
i'm in awe yeah safe to say shannon's
feeling the same he can't help bug gush
over zoe skills behind the camera she's
just killing it we're we're here and and
we're we're all and it's like a weird
little like summer camp where we're in
this like beautiful hacienda in the
yucatan
and uh and we're we're doing some really
really cool stuff
and it's super stylized and and and yet
really fun but has like a very deep and
um
i think a shocking sort of uh message at
some point i was going to ask what made
her the perfect person to do this but i
think you just said it she saw you she
saw who you she's got a weird gift for
that uh she sees right through a lot of
people's stuff and really kind of just
who they are to her is really simple
like and she's one of the more
intentional people i've ever met in my
life the film is expected out next year
so in the meantime we'll entertain
ourselves with the couple's off-screen
antics
[Music]
you